Here's how we can solve this.
We have our cipher text c.
We have our public key component e.
The key point here is that when m is small, if m^e is less than n,
then we never wrapped around the modulus.
That means decryption is as easy as finding these eth of the cipher text.
What we're looking for is the eth root of c.
We can compute that in Python using the pow function.
So 1 divided by 17 will give us the 17th root of c.
We get the message was 7.
This means decrypting is very easy if m^e is less than n.
This is also true if m^e is less than some multiple of n.
We can try just adding n to the cipher text and taking the eth root.
If we ever get an integer result, that's a good indication that that was the message.